e
okay we'll open up the executive
session uh just want to uh let the
committee know that next week uh Tuesday
is town meeting day so we will not be
meeting at all um so we we will be
meeting on Wednesday um we've heard all
our bills so the only thing we really
have left um is uh subcommittees and and
I will try to actually uh schedule all
remaining 23 bills uh as subcommittees
for next week some of them are actually
already been done taken care of but that
will go through everything and that
leads the following week uh for time for
us to um wrap up those bills and that um
we have to have everything out of the
committee on the 20th so we would
probably be having an exec session the
day the 19th uh in the morning uh
similar to this where we get all our
work
done
okay okay one two three four five six
7even 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 I would
quorum I guess the next count is how our
mix okay okay 1
2 three four five 6 7
nine
one did I count wrong somewhere you said
six one two three no one two
oh I did Count wrong so it's 10 we're
10 right because we have one two four
five
six I guess my math is bad today we have
nine we have nine okay and that means
there had to be has to be seven dams
[Laughter]
four
have why am i counting numbers wrong how
many people are here total again I
16 so there has have 15 there's two
two three four five six you know I
myself
two three four five six
four n and six nine and six is correct
okay N9 to seven
okay yes all
right okay first bill uh House Bill 185
uh relative to reimbursement rat for
ambulance service provider
representative spear second might
representative pusk moves in expedient
to
legislate as you all know this is the
one that uh uh We've is The Perennial
one um and uh it basically is an any
willing provider for the ambulance
company so whatever they want to be paid
they get paid uh which is problematic at
best any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate the only thing I'd like to say
yeah is that by having it
such that the pro the ambulance service
is provid is is getting paid whatever it
is that they require doesn't allow this
committee to evaluate what the impact on
premiums will be because the impact is
different depending on where they are so
I think it's important to hold this and
to make note of the fact that we have
two other bills that we are working very
hard on that deal with the same issue
that at least help us bound the problem
and bound the issue so it's not like
it's going to go away way it's just a
matter of well that's why we're itail
because this one is just a non-starter
so okay the motion clear is inexpedient
to legislate on 185 and the clerk will
role uh represent sorry representative
puchek yes
Osborne Ammon yes Cole yes the clerk
says
here representative Walsh yes
representative miles yes representative
presea yes representative
burrow representative Herbert not
here representative mcclear yes
representative spear yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Sol Sullivan
yes representative Teresa yes
representative salvi yes okay
representative H and representative
H yes one two three four five six seven
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 17 to two
the vote is theous 16 to zip all those
in favor in placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
moved
that 16 zip I thought it was 17 zip oh
right yes we're now 9 to S so that we're
16 people
here I had 17 and uh representative
spear made the
motion okay House Bill 186 uh relative
to the legalization and regulation of
cannabis and making Appropriations there
are uh representative Sullivan moves to
retain second by representative Hunt is
there any discussion on the retain any
motion ye yes yeah I so I just want to
say my motivation behind this so that
people are aware is the most important
thing is that we stop arresting people
in 2025 for the possession of marijuana
and while this bill would do this I
think the complicated part that
continues to trip trip up Us in the
legislature uh historically has been the
the method by which we're going to sell
it in the state so I think retaining
this will give us a chance to kind of
flesh out some of those details
it sound at at our initial subcommittee
hearing on this um we all kind of
acknowledge that that's a steep hill to
climb to allow legalization and sale and
so hopefully this will give us some time
in the fall to talk about this and
hopefully come to some agreement and I
look forward to passing something in
January at least out of the
house okay any other discussion on the
retain so uh question so so right now we
are voting to just retain the bill not
to
say we're not passing it we're not
killing it we're retaining it we're
retaining it and for those of you who
are new uh what happens in retaining
bills is that we uh will work on them uh
come
September and October and then it will
hit the house floor the first week of
January so I I high recommend do not
make any plans that first week of
January because that's actually a very
exciting time because that means all the
bills that were in committee they're all
retaining committees will hit the floor
exciting
okay okay uh clerk will call the role on
retain
so uh
representative Pok yes Pok uh
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes the
clerk says yes uh representative pelli
is not
here um representative Walsh yes
representative miles yes representative
Pressa yes representative buroughs yes
representative Herbert yes
representative M yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative s Sullivan yes represent
representative terasa yes representative
yes
uh
okay vote is 17 to zero all those in
favor of placing oh that's it's retain
bill so it's
doesn't go anywhere okay next
up
170 next up one yes we had a one not
here one not here right okay House Bill
241 relative to treatment alternative uh
to opioids um I I move to retain this
bill second by representative
burough um basically um we're we've been
working on it and the uh sponsor uh
wasn't able to make the subcommittee
yesterday and requested that we just
hold on to the bill so that we can
continue to work on it and and see what
we're where we're at come September and
I was agreeable to
that okay so the motion is to
retain
241 clerk will call the
role representative puchek yes
representative Osborne y representative
anaman yes representative Cole yes
representative post says yes
representative Peli is not here
representative Walsh yes representative
miles yes representative Pressa yes
representative burough yes
representative Herbert representative
melier yes representative spear yes
representative Gibbs yes representative
Sullivan yes representative chasa yes
representative salvi yes representative
okay
um okay so I just had a panic moment
here
um how many people H we have the
Amendments uh to like this next bill the
18 to the all the committee
okay okay all right I won't won't Panic
no
Panic okay all right so representative
Ammon second by representative pusc
moves uh ought to pass on the amendment
Krist could next couple of bills we have
amendments for which I think are going
to be stuck in in their files you mind
just going in the files and so we have
them in case and people need to see them
okay all right uh represent Ammon
recognized speak to his
motion yeah thank you Mr chair so the
amendment uh to House Bill 302
simplifies the bill somewhat it it takes
out uh some of the things that were
probably too complicated for this period
in time um things about stable tokens
and staking stable tokens uh but
basically what the bill does as amended
is the treasurer has a list of approved
Investments that they're able to make
and this uh bill would add digital
assets above a certain threshold so uh
high quality digital assets and then
also precious metals and the likely uh
the likely uh method would probably be
an ETF which would be an an extra an
exchange traded product um the treasurer
expressed interest in having the option
uh but is uh still determining when when
they would use use it when she would use
it so uh with that all for the
amendment okay any discussion on the
motion about about to pass on the
amendment so represent sha I do have a
question on this so does this bill also
mentions the mix or is it to be
whoever yes so the the original Bill had
up to 10% of funds and this drops it
down to up to 5% so it's between zero
and 5% would be authorized by the
legislation so so there's there's a a
maximum of a small percentage okay and
the second question would be that so
will the
person State treasure oh oh this is a
okay okay you said okay yes represent
thank you uh what is the definition of
assets is it's in the bill um under
definition should be over the top of the
so there's a market so there's a market
capitalization an annual market
capitalization of 500 billion so half of
a trillion so for a digital asset to be
considered by the treasurer under this
bill it would have to have at least a
market cap of half a trillion dollars in
the previous year so that that sets a a
very high threshold should for uh you
know it's not it's not meme coins it's
not you know uh tokens that people are
playing with it's serious digital assets
that companies and countries are are
considering putting on the balance sheet
including the United States government
amendment yes represen Gibbs yeah thank
you um
uh I know that's a very high threshold
um but our digital assets regardless of
the threshold sufficiently reliable to
money so that would be the determination
for the treasurer uh this gives gives
her the option to do it it doesn't
mandate that she does it so it's it's a
it it can be a volatile field but over
the long
term there there are smart people that
think that there's an upside potential
investigating um any other questions
yeah I do have I do have followup uh
so so the treasurer will there be checks
and balance on the treasurer or is there
a committee who's going to decide about
it's called
Moody I'm sorry moody moody is the
bonding Council and they will if they
think that she's made a bad decision
they will lower our rating so she is
very conscious of making sure that she
will make that the capital markets uh
whatever she's doing is is is done to
not be at risk are you referring to the
standard Moody rating for all the bonds
and everything
exactly
okay okay the clerk will call the role
whatting on the amendment Amendment the
amendment uh yes representative Osborne
yes representative Ammon yes
representative Cole yes representative
post says yes representative Peli is not
here representative Walsh yes
representative miles yes representative
Pressa yes representative burough yes
no
rep representative melier yes
representative spear yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Sullivan
representative terasa yes representative
Sai yes okay yes representative hunts
I'm sorry I include you when okay the
motion is now representative Ammon
seconded by representative burough moves
ought to pass as amended is any
pass what was the
number right we have a total amount of
people of 18 in this committee right 17
so it would be have to be 16 to one
16 your math is bad as mine
today I'm still on the mountain you see
why I spent some time doing that a time
so are we on this so right now we're on
okay we just done a toath say Amon and P
you the amendment right where which what
sheet of paper did you do the amendment
on so I actually did it on this one
thinking we were doing
this on exec
session okay cuz we did the other ones
on this this is the first one you should
have the amendment number on there not
to pass it says amendment
number
yeah3 okay okay and the vote was 16 to
one okay so now the put motion
representative
did okay is the question clear the clerk
will call the
role okay so this this would be this
role correct which I already
get on this so I'll well check them
again no you technically you're supposed
to do a separate so we do okay so this
is our to pass as amended as
amend
TPA and so this is on
okay so um we're on and uh
representative Puchi yes Osborne yes
Ammon yes Cole yes clerk is yes brelli
is not here uh representative Walsh
miles Yesa yes burrow yes Herbert
no mat yes spear yes Gibbs
yes Sullivan yes terasa yes salvi yes
okay and so same
thing and representative hun
yes hand
over okay don't forget me so we're out
the two the same as the last is here
he's a a he is a a yeah not this is not
available okay oh so we're going to put
him here yes CU he's in okay here
okay and take that
out okay so that's 17 to
one 16 to
one oh because she's gone so okay any
Minority
Report do do you want because otherwise
i' leave it on the regular calendar
calendar you you have that determination
power consent
okay all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I those
unanimously consent on 302 yes consent
16 to one and did we
put you yeah so then yeah so down here
okay
okay all right what's next
uh 451 establishing the paint product
stewardship program representative spear
making the motion uh seconded by
representative hunt
number I this is what I've just I I came
here early today to make sure this I had
the all the ducks in a row and then I
got a little we
laid
okay you
have sorry we couldn't be more exciting
for
you yes we will'll end up on the editing
floor
today okay let all right number
they
without
I'm so we were we
resp not personally I didn't
rep
it
I
[Music]
better I don't think the mining is that
one why don't we just retain it and like
dig into it a little bit more being
rushed
rain this was
is
okay right this is the right one good I
it looked it looked good to me when I
looked read it because I all I did is
look in the back and there was no money
in it so I know it was good
okay you all right we are back in
session okay uh exec session so we have
House Bill
451 establishing the paint product
stewardship program representative spear
moves off to pass on amendment number
H okay yes this is exactly the bill that
we were looking at the other time it's
just now formal correct okay and is this
correct yep and it's not to pass yet it
it's ought to pass the motion is ought
to pass on the amendment okay okay yes
represent Gibs um since we just got this
amendment yes um could somebody uh give
us a brief explanation of what changed
from the original Bill to this amendment
absolutely so what we did with this
amendment is that
um fundamentally most important thing we
did is we took the money out of it there
is no at this point that the
um the paint
manufacturers um are responsible for the
funding mechanism and that will be built
into the cost of the paint and will be
unbeknownst to us the idea is that um it
is a marketing program for them they
want to be able to say that they uh have
a little sticker on their pack on their
paints and say uh we'll we'll take back
any paint and even if this is not the
can you've got another can in the paint
laying around the house bring it on in
and we'll take it back for you and uh so
this is a um uh a program we're just is
enabling legislation uh it has been
passed in many other states but in other
states they they had money involved and
and as far as I was concerned the money
was a tax and we don't we don't do taxes
in New Hampshire so in this way um if if
there if whatever cost it is because the
paints the man the manufacturer The
Entity that's taking the paint back is a
is is controlled by the manufacturers so
for all tens of purposes this is their
their their uh nature of their business
is to now take back any unused paint so
will not be attacks um I had some
problems with the original bill because
it seems to be overly complex is this
any simpler oh yes I I think this is a
model of Simplicity
and uh common uh we passed we did get a
copy of this bill before it just didn't
have a number on it and we went through
it in a lot of detail uh one thing that
should be pointed out is that we had all
the sponsors here and they were asked
how they have felt about this bill as it
is modified and they were fully on board
with it they said it does everything
that they wanted to do right and Dees
was was great you know grateful that uh
that this this is a and obviously um
waste management companies and and
everybody who who does deal with garbage
they are happy happy that we are
implementing this program um it is it is
you know obviously very one of the one
of the let see the the I how to be funny
about it but you know it's it was it's
always been a problem for solid waste
you know everybody to do what to do with
old paint and people have been leaving
it in their basement and not doing it
and now they have a golden opportunity
that to take it into the local hardware
store or local whatever paint store
nearby and home and get rid of it so so
just to make sure that uh when a person
purchases the paint in the store they
won't see anything on their receipt uh
indicating this price is ATT has because
of this Over My Dead Body will we charge
you okay the motion is ought to pass on
the
amendment representative Puchi yes
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes the
clerk says yes Susan Susan purcelli is
not here today representative Walsh yes
representative miles yes representative
preza yes representative Burrows yes
representative Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative Gib chance to
get representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan yes repres
representative terasa yes representative
sorry 17
17 okay 17 to nothing 17 to nothing so
um representative did you actually have
an a blurb written on this already
yeah you did you email because yeah we
already you you really want to write the
it okay that's okay sorry
sorry uh how about I'll find another one
for you how's
that no no it's fine let's take it okay
representative spear second by
representative press moves to pass as
amended any discussion on the motion
seeing none the clerk will call the
role
okay here we go so this is not to
pass and representative puchek yes
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes
representative uh post says yes porcel
is nay she's not here she is not here um
representative Walsh yes representative
miles yes representative
presea yes representative burough yes
representative Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan representative
terasa representative salvi yes
representative hunt yes okay and that is
17 to Z all those in favor placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
those closed so moved
unanimously okay House Bill 499 making
technical corrections to certain
Insurance
laws4 okay uh I I'm make a motion second
by representative Bros uh ought to pass
on the amendment number 364 h o
okay okay so this bill has a you know
any number I think it was seven
different items of different statutes
that uh insurance department had um
on anybody have any questions
all
right see none the clerk will call the
role representative puchek yes
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes the
clerk says yes Peli is out uh
representative Walsh representative
miles yes representative Pressa yes
representative Burrows yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Maier yes representative
spear representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan representative
terasa yes representative salvi
representative hunt
yes votes passed 17 to zip yes the
motion is now ought to pass as amended
is any discussion on the motion seeing
none the clerk will call the
role okay oh excuse me representative
hunt second by representative
paper one more okay this is ought to
pass on
pucha
okay representative Puchi yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Cole yes representative post is here yes
pcel is out representative Walsh yes
representative miles yes representative
Pressa yes representative burrow yes
representative Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative terazza yes
representative salvi yes okay 17 to zip
motion carries 17 to zip all those in
favor placing on the consent Calendar
unanimously okay 538 relocating posss in
The Liquor Commission representative
Pressa seconded by representative pusc
moves a to pass on the amendment
number this is 49 oh I'm sorry it you're
right it is a ought to pass on this
one to
there is no Amendment no evidently there
wasn't there only 10
lines we are was there any Amendment on
this bill
Mark
okay thank you
okay right no I see I was looking at the
wrong thing yes okay um the motion is
ought to pass there any discussion on
the motion seeing none the clerk will
let me
lot halfway through take the
r
yeah all right I'll keep
that and this is for 538 yep 538 motion
is ought to
pass and that is uh representative
puchek uh yes representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Cole yes the clerk is yes pcel is out
representative Walsh yes representative
miles yes representative Pressa yes
representative burough representative
Herbert yes representative melier yes
representative spear yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Sullivan yes
representative chaza yes representative
salvi yes okay 17 to zero yes and
representative
hunt by the end of the day you'll got
that figured out yeah hopefully okay the
motion Carri 17 to zip all those in
favor of putting it on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
move
damous okay I'll spill 552 relative to
coverage of children under the state
retire insurance plan representative
spear
you were going to do this one this is
the um coverage for children under the
state insurance and this
is do you have this one on
your
one
okay
okay representative spear second by
representative hunt uh moves out to pass
on 552
you remember what this was
about this this was the glitch in our
the system that that how long do I get
to write the
blurb what's that how long do I get to
write the blurb you need to have it done
by noon can I dictate it dict I don't
something2 otherwise I'll do it
okay um yeah so this is just a clean up
making sure that uh it was a kind of a
glitch in the state retirement chance
didn't identify um uh children who might
be under 16 but how can be a state
employee who's retired but still have
children under 26 but who who are are to
ask how many others are those but the
key thing about this is that the person
who is insured who is covered under the
retirement plan pays for their children
anyway it's not like state is paying for
the children just makes it eligible in
the program
correct if you're you're a state
employee that's retired and you and it's
up till
yes they can actually drink too yes
represent Ammon yes so this bill is very
simple It just strikes the requirement
that the child under 26 has to be a
student so that and that was the Old Law
that's yeah right a
re
okay and it's out to pass and it's off
to pass is the motion clear the clerk
role representative pic
yes representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Cole yes the clerk is yes priscilia is
out representative
Walsh representative miles yes
representative Presa yes representative
burrow yes representative Herbert yes
representative mclair yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan representative
terasa yes representative salvi yes 17
to zero okay the motion carries
representative hunt does say yes
representative hun motion carries 17 to
zip um all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
unanimously okay uh relative to the use
and disputes of blockchain and digital
currencies representative spear second
by representative M and M ought to pass
amendment the motion is a to pass a to
this is the Block Chain okay
yeah have more represented spear you
want to speak to your
motion uh right uh the we we spent quite
a bit of
time uh working over the bill and
figuring out what we liked or didn't
like about it and as a result of that uh
some very important changes were
made uh and some very important things
were eliminated but one of the important
things the changes that were made and I
think is should be noted by everyone is
that uh blockchain businesses if they if
they the blockchain itself is a
technology it is not a business it
becomes a business when somebody does
something with the blockchain and if
they choose to do data mining we've read
in the news a lot of problems with very
large data mining
operations that uh use a lot of energy a
lot of noise and make a lot of noise
what we did in this bill in the
amendment was to take the noise and and
delegate it down to the municipality so
whever such a thing was ever to exist if
somebody wanted to make an application
to put a data mining business as an IND
industry into a town that town has the
right to set a noise level and that
noise level would apply to any business
that went into it so that seems PR
pretty reasonable blockchain it could
has to be the same it would be the same
for any business and it would be very
limiting to a blockchain operation if
they tried to be big but the other thing
and and I I I have to stress
this in the state of New Hampshire we
pay the highest uh the eighth highest
electric rates in the
country data mining businesses use a lot
of
electricity this is not the state
they're going to come to to set up a
data mining
operation and on top of that 52% of our
electricity comes from nuclear which is
going to be retired in 2050 and we have
no replacement for it so I can only
Envision by 2050 that we're either going
to pay more for electricity or I don't
know what we're going to do but the
point is we are not an attractive site
for a large scale data mining operation
so I think that the complaints that were
against this bill
regarding energy usage are just
misinformed this is not the place where
they're going to set that up now you
could do home data mining you know in
your house with with a bunch of
computers you can do that but if you try
to do that in an apartment an apartment
has the right to say based on the the
your rental agreement that you can't
disturb the piece and it's the same
thing that would be in a condominium
that they have bylaws that say you can't
make this kind of noise if you should
make enough noise chances are you
probably can't the noise is air
conditioners right so what's left in the
bill is something that's that kind of
says okay we're we we blockchains are
okay businesses based on blockchains are
okay uh but there's a lot of Hoops
you're going to have to go through
essentially you know I mean and and in
all honesty people should understand
that we're working on bill hp310 which
sets up a whole commission to study how
these businesses are going to be
regulated so this is just to
limit the
noise and a few little items and also to
set up a docket which doesn't cost
anything uh the docket itself I want to
mention uh is is only allowed it is not
mandated is not required so I mean if
the H Judicial System wants to set one
up if the governor wants to set one up
fine if he doesn't want to he doesn't
have to so the bill itself is uh pretty
straightforward and pretty pretty
innocuous I I would have to say it just
gets the words out there and one thing I
do like about it it has a lot of
definitions that a lot of people don't
know about and I think the definitions
alone are worth having this thing out
there that's what I have to say about
that represent Ammon did you want to
yeah that's a pretty good overview um so
the energy usage there there's talk
about using it's called high performance
compute HPC so the AI data centers and
digital asset mining can can partner
with uh new energy sources we heard just
today we heard just today that
geothermal is a big Push by by the
administration small modular reactors
you know I'm a big fan of that and
Mining can help make those projects
initially profitable so it may not be uh
in the current state uh advisable to
mine in New Hampshire because of our
energy rates but this could help
incentivize New Generation true which is
kind of kind of cool and I just wanted
to stress the uh the blockchain dispute
docket was a recommendation from the
governor's uh digital asset Commission
it's one of the recommendations that we
hadn't implemented yet so I'm glad to
see that's carried forward with this
represent San thank you Mr chair um I'm
actually GNA vote against this
motion I think that this is a as as was
mentioned in in the testimoni in initial
hearing this is a bill that is not
actually addressing a problem it's sort
of prophylactic if you will and so I
think there I would I would prefer just
to be on record I would prefer for
retaining this bill so we could work on
it understand it better and let some of
the people who have been reaching out to
us in recent weeks have a chance to sort
of digest this amendment that just came
out basically last night to them um I
think that much of what representative
spear is true I agree at the current
state with electricity prices in New
Hampshire very high at the national
level it's unlikely we'll see such a
large Center that I think is what is
scaring a lot of people nevertheless
things could change in the future where
New Hampshire suddenly be becomes
cheaper energy and and these regulations
are um something that don't need to be
rushed through and I think it'd be okay
if we waited a little bit to sort of
digest this amendment and let some of
the people who are act activists on this
space have a chance to digest it and
then you know maybe come in and work
with us in the fall so that would be my
preference so I'm going to vote against
this and if this motion doesn't pass
that would be my recommendation is to
put a next Motion in to
retain representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um the problem
I have the amendment uh is a problem
that I had with the original bill as
well and that is the fact that um under
um oo 359 V3 section 3B um municipality
uh aside from the noise which um has
been changed to the benefit of
municipalities municipalities cannot
impose any requirement on a digital
mining business that does not equally
apply to all industrial Zone Pro
properties and the problem I have with
that is the energy us usage problem I
understand the fact that digital mining
operations are not that likely to come
to New Hampshire and that does make
sense and I understand that there are
possibilities uh for the future as to
less energy intensive methods of digital
mining but that is still spec
speculative and I think that um if a
digital mining uh operation is going to
be located in New Hampshire that the
municipality should have the option of
controlling the energy usage um and so
uh so long as that's in there I cannot
support the amendment or the bill uh I
think that should be left to the
commission um as one of the things that
they should
consider um so I guess
point out to everybody when you look at
the bill uh on the very first page uh
purpose and
findings and I I do this because
um I I want to remind everybody that
this might be the only time you'll ever
read this because once a bill is put in
the statute this
disappears and it uh would only be in
those little yellow books on on session
session books and what's important is
that the purpose of the commission that
was
created well and the purpose as as
stated here is that New Hampshire wants
to say that we
want this Tech new technology we want
companies to consider come to New
Hampshire and do business here we're
inviting them to do business
here so
can a zoning board or someone you know
say you know uh worry about the
electrical usage of this industry
versus aluminum making which has a huge
amount of electrical usage no it's not
appropriate that we that they either can
say you can Zone you can Zone and say
yeah you can come in and and you know do
a factory or not but to to say you could
pick out an industry and pick on them
then that is really does fly so I
understand you know you have pressures
from your communities who are are kind
of freaked out about it and and that
that can happen um but at the end of the
day it's whether they would want to
invite one of these companies to being
to to come to their
town and and so it's a lot more than
just this legislation and this is just a
little examp a public state of State of
New Hampshire says we want to be
inviting but I understand in terms of
you know whether you have those concerns
but uh no I I don't think it's
appropriate to you know to to have spot
zoning and say okay well this particular
industry we're not going to allow you to
do it simply because you're electrical
consumer where there's plenty of other
industries that are huge electrical
consumers um I was looking at that just
today I was noticing this old store
there was a storefront that was used to
be an ague type store and and I noticed
that they had three-phase power coming
to there and that three-phase power is
very expensive because this was like
three or four this is right outside of
Peter bro there was three or four miles
to get that three-phase power to that
location and it's sitting empty right
now so um to the idea is that we want to
be inviting and that's that's the
purpose of this legislation and the
zoning is specifically says is don't try
to pick on this one industry and try to
be accepting and and supportive yes
representative Gibs uh thank you Mr
chair um usually the reason that we
would want to invite an industry to come
to the state is because it would provide
jobs does digital mining provide jobs
absolutely it provides jobs somebody's
got to be sitting in front of that
computer typing in stuff to get the
computer to do what it's supposed to
do sorry that would be one person it's
not like a factory that would provide
hundreds of jobs when I've heard sto
about the huge entities that are doing
this I can't imagine that they only have
one person
inside but representative Ammon uh could
you provide any additional information
on that we could I mean I feel like
we've beaten this bill of death we've
talked about it in two subcommittee
hearings so it feel like we're
retreading uh ground that we've gone
over for weeks and the amendment was not
available last night I emailed it to the
committee on February 18th so we've had
a couple of weeks to just his his
constituents that being on the housing
committee I wasn't able to attend all
the subcommittee meetings no so for me
you're not retre right representative
melier uh thank you very much I I think
we would learn more about how this is
going to work by not putting it on the
back table I think we should pass the
bill um we may find that there are
things going on that we need to add to
it or change to it but you know let's
get it out there and and see what
you thank you for taking my question I
just wanted to know about a little bit
more about the compliance cost related
to it because I have done some research
in New York basically many of these
operations got closed because of the
compliance cost so did we think about it
what kind of compliance cost we have is
it something doable we don't want lot of
business to come and then they just
close the
business yeah so when you go into
business you risk your own Capital right
so that's up to the business uh you know
owners to decide now you mentioned New
York which is a neighboring state you
know a nearby State and they did exactly
that they put a a moratorium on mining
they drove all the miners out of their
state we're right next door you know
potentially we could send you know a
signal with the bill that we're open for
business and one thing we're not
considering is tax revenue so if you
have a a if you have a business that's
making millions and millions of dollars
through mining they're going to pay tax
to the state and and local community for
property tax so you know there's
benefits to this including jobs thank
you okay one more one more time
representa gives thank you Mr chair um
excuse me but I would like to go back to
representative Ammon with my question
about jobs because I really don't know
yeah so a mining operation involves
electricians it involves computer
scientists it involves uh people that
keep the grounds maintain the building
right so there's a lot of jobs some of
them are high technical jobs involved in
maintaining these mining operations and
you know when you buy a cell phone in a
couple years after you buy it it becomes
more and more obsolete right so the same
thing happens
with these mining computers because it's
a giant race it's a it's a global
competition this these mining operations
so they have to keep up they have to
replace their Hardware every so often to
to make sure it's more efficient and uh
is more competitive with their Global
competition in order to find the digital
assets uh in the mining operation so
there's a continual upgrade that needs
to happen so all that contributes to job
creation
okay question clear is or ought to pass
on the amendment clerk will call the
role okay um representative Puchi yes
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes the
clerk says yes Susan pcell is not here
representative Walsh representative
miles yes representative Pressa yes
representative buroughs yes
representative Herbert
no representative melier yes rep
representative spear yes representative
Gibbs no representative Sullivan
no representative terasa yes
representative salvi yes okay so we are
okay motion carries representative hunt
hunt yes sir even I'm getting to forget
myself 14 to okay 14 motions 14 to three
now the motion uh representative spear
second by representative Manon moves
ought to pass as amended and discussion
on the motion I think
we've not enough we do it we do another
one
with and so that is uh representative
Puchi yes representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Cole yes representative post is here yes
Susan pcel is not here uh representative
Walsh yes representative miles yes
representative Presa yes representative
buroughs yes representative Herbert no
no representative melier yes
representative spear yes representative
Gibbs no Representative solivan no
representative terazza yes
representative salvi yes representative
hunt
yes
okay we finally have a bill on the
regular
calendar okay is there going to be a
is there are you going to write a
Minority
Report okay so you you today this
morning okay this afternoon yeah this
afterno yeah as quickly as possible yes
all right what's the minority motion and
yeah what would your motion
be what is your motion oh sorry it okay
okay um excuse me representative
Sullivan when I've written the um
Minority Report would you take a look at
it with
me
648 okay so for 648 yeah so this
is is 6:39 we're doing okay we're not
done yet oh okay so with
639 you're going to go um down down
you're going to put in the vote and then
you have the amendment number this is 14
H correct okay okay so you write that
here
okay okay and we say adoption turn
adopted okay and then we have down here
going click on regular calendar and
Gibs Gibbs
gibs and her motion should say her
motion and and her motion
is
it
okay
have this is the blur by right I wanted
to add should I give it to you or should
Rob
yeah here here I'll tell you what let me
initial
it okay all right next up so this is 4
so that
was okay next up is 648 relative to
insurance coverage for glucose
monitoring um she left the room so um I
move I move to retain uh this bill
648 so it'll be me and second by
representative spear uh basically we we
had an amendment we're we're been trying
to work around the good terms of how to
find the resolve the big issue was
finding out exactly where the committee
is on this um the science is actually
um in terms of of what what is what
medications you should be taking because
it seems to be right now insurance
companies allow you to get these
monitorings units um if you are um uh
taking
um SP insulin insulin yeah taking
insulin so um it turns out that that
there is some you know the question is
what they say like like I take met
Foreman is that does that make me
qualify to get one of these and uh
because I've just reached the the A1C
number threshold so we clearly we need
to know a little more what is the where
what is the proper threshold what of
when we think it's appropriate to have
these devices I know that represent
Teresa believes that uh if your doctor
says you you should get it then to get
it you should just be able to get it um
and and but
um at the end of the day the the doctor
doesn't is not driven by Insurance the
issue is that um someone might say well
gee I I'm afraid of blood I'm I'm afraid
of I'm afraid of pinking my pitching my
finger I don't want to do this or
something like that and the doctor says
okay fine you should get this device
well then we find out that this device
is incredibly expensive and and and in
that you know when maybe the patient
really didn't need it their their their
um sugar level you know is not that bad
and so whether they have the test you
know get it so we would say sure go
ahead and get it but you you know in
terms of the having the doctor order it
but to have the pharmaceutical company
you know having insurance companies
having to pay for something that you're
doing it because you you have pin
pricking fingers issues or those kind of
things seem a little uh unnecessary yeah
I I do have I you know so like you
mentioned the main opposition was that
because right now it's the insurance
company they are deciding the medical
eligibility of the device which is I
feel is not it shouldn't be that way
the the eligibility of the device should
be determined by the doctor who is
seeing the patient because it's the
doctor to understand patient much better
than an insurance company can understand
now the scenario that you mentioned that
somebody can just say okay I am you know
uh afraid of you know poking every day
so I need a medical device like that the
situation scenario you presented I don't
think the doctor is going to prescribe
just based on that and if the doctor
prescribes based on that then probably
doctor has the doctor in all good faith
should be writing a report like that
that I'm prescribing this because my
patient is afraid of getting uh you know
poked every day so there there goes the
medical eligibility that's a convenience
it's not a Med medical eligibility my my
take was that when you decide a medical
eligibility of a situation between
patient and doctor it's the doctor
should be the one who understands and
they should be the one who decides that
this is really required for that uh
situation to not get worse for the uh uh
for the diabetes to not get out of
control
because diabetes is not just one reading
that you poke and take the reading
sometimes you know that sometime A1C can
give you right right value sometimes uh
you know you might have a right A1C
however your blood color fluctuate
depending upon the time of the day
depending upon what you eat so there
there are a lot of factors which only
doctor understand is so all I just want
to make it simple that the eligibility
should be decided by the doctor and not
the insurance company and if the doctor
makes a you know some exception because
of convenience then the doctor will put
that and obviously in that case the
pharmacy and the insurance company can
reject it because it's a convenience is
not a medical requirement there's a
difference of word and that's exactly
why we need to retain it to figure out
how we're going to write that language
that's the devil in the detail here that
we trying to figure out how do we make
sure that that the doctor's intent is
based on the medical necessity not
because it's convenient or uh I assume
that when doctor start practicing they
do they do they do
write yeah this is your first time in
the term and that this is a great bill
for you to understand exactly that Dr
patient SL insurance company Department
relationship and you're going to learn a
lot today Mr chair this is this is a
this is not a subcommittee this is an
exact session and I don't think we
should be legislating the bill right now
okay so you can vote no on retaining
that's fine but I'm saying right now we
want that uh the motion is to retain
this bill uh we will talk you know work
on it over the you know in come
September okay we can work it further
you say we in September every bill
that's retained okay has to be is worked
on in September and October remember I
talked about this before in September
and October and gets voted on uh out of
the committee and it's on the house
floor the first week of January remember
right I talked about how you want to be
around the first week of January because
all the bills that are retained which is
like this one will be voted on by the
Full House on in
January so okay so basically certain
wordings you you want to just go through
wsh uh I thought the delineating factor
of this was if the person had to inject
insulin I thought that's I'm searching
for it in
verbage was that's a decision we have to
make yeah so I'm all for making that the
delineating factor yes okay
representative
spear I I don't really want to I don't
want to prolong
this okay all right the motion is to
retain the clerk will call the
role representative Puchi yes
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes the
clerk says yes priscilia is not here
representative Walsh yes representative
miles yes representative Pressa yes
representative buroughs yes
representative Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative terasa yes representative
salvi yes okay representative H
representative
hunt in the old days I didn't have to
vote at all I know the only have but
to we don't like reports for uh things
that are retained do we we don't no
reports
yeah okay uh next bill House Bill 733
relative to reporting requirements of
persons or entities financing
lawsuits
okay we have 631 H okay 631 H all right
representative Cole yes let make a
motion like make a motion to pass
Amendment
0726 H
0726 yes is that the latest one yes no
we got that was yesterday that was
yesterday yeah we don't you remember we
bill okay and this is for
Okay representative Cole and seconded by
representative
burough and representative Cole is
recognized to speak to his motion we
took out the consumer portion and the
reporting is now going to go through the
changes representative Cole does this
include the stuff we talked about
yesterday yeah yes it does we took out
the language that they wanted taken out
okay but it still includes the foreign
entities correct right right we put the
we we first took the foreign out and
then and then we said no we really don't
we don't want foreign entities to
and so no loans from Hong Kong
okay so uh the motion is ought to pass
on the
amendment question clear the clerk will
call the role representative puchek yes
representative Osborne representative
Ammon yes representative Cole yes
representative post says yes prelia is
not here representative Walsh
representative miles yes representative
preza yes representative burrow yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Maier yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative teraza yes representative
salvi yes 17 to zero representative HT
yes okay the motion is now ought to pass
as amended representative
Cole second representative Burrows oh
here we do this one now right yeah you
do that first and we have this and do we
do
moving adoption amend to pass as amended
stay okay okay question is clear clerk
role and um we have representative Puchi
yes representative
Osborne representative Ammon yes
representative Cole yes representative
post is here yes Susan pelia is not here
representative Walsh yes representative
miles yes representative preza yes
representative burough yes
representative Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan representative
terazza yes representative salvi yes
yes okay motion passes to zip all those
in favor of placing on the consent
Calendar please say I those
unanimously we put the two people on
that are no we don't do we
yeah okay house
bill for the next one 7 hosal
774 uh requiring Medicare supplemental
policies to cover pre-existing
conditions representative spear second
by representative hunt moves inexpedient
to
legislate would you like to speak to
your
motion yeah I
guess you don't have
most of us are familiar with the way I
do things in this
committee and I
spent every single hour of every single
day during the time off that we had when
a lot of people went on vacation
but one of the things I found is if you
go online and you can find a lot of
misinformation and what I chose to do is
only accept information that was either
issued by CMS the cers for Medicare and
Medicaid systems or whatever they call
it and the Kaiser Family Foundation
those are the only two organizations
that I felt would give me the
absolute bottom line of what was going
on as I presented in the
subcommittee Medicare Part B deductibles
as of 2020 are
gone there are no supplemental plans
that pay for that anymore there was a
plan F but that got discontinued there
was a plan C by the way I loved Plan F
there was a plan C but that became
Medicare uh
Advantage there are some plans out there
uh G and N I think I I didn't bring the
paper with me but there are a couple of
plans that will pay Medicare part A
deductibles but that is if you are in a
hospital for more than a 100 days it
will pick up the deductible that happens
after a 100
days so right now according to kff kaisa
Family Foundation the recommendation is
typically unless you live in two St
States you want to go with Medicare
Advantage and the reason I say that is
the network for
Medicare standard with a supplemental
even whether you have a supplemental or
not the network is the entire United
States with Medicare Advantage the
network is more local that is to say
within a couple of states of where you
live for instance Nash uh New Hampshire
and Massachusetts would be a region of
coverage and Medicare
Advantage in the now when medic Care
Advantage has a it's almost a cons
sliding scale a continuous scale from
the very least expensive to the very
most expensive so what depends on your
coverage is the size of your network and
your network can be as small as the town
of Nashua and as large as the as the
area of Nash of New Hampshire
Massachusetts then it depends on the
depth of the doctors it can be 30% of
the doctors in that area all the way up
to 70% of the doctors in that area and
you pay for what you want and you pick
out what you want and it's not easy but
you can do that and they and I put
together some tables that I sent to
everybody that showed the research of
what that is the biggest advantage to
Medicare Advantage is that you can go
from one plan to another plan every
single year and your and your uh
pre-existing condition is
covered there was a lot of questions
about well people are very dissatisfied
with Medicare Advantage yes that was the
case up until about four years ago
they've done some improvements whatever
it is but according to the kaisa Family
Foundation the acceptance rate or the
the number of people that are pleased
with their Medicare Advantage is now up
around
95% according to CMS the number of
people that move from Medicare Advantage
to Medicare standard is about 2% and
back and forth It's both ways that's
switching in both directions so that I
don't we can't do much with that
information but 95% raise uh success
rate for a medical coverage plan to me
is almost phenomenal but that's just you
know that's my opinion the point is the
cases that were brought to US during the
hearing that we
discussed it was not clear to any there
was we did never we never got enough
information to figure out why whatever
Medicare Advantage plan they had had
failed in that particular case that we
were given we were not
told and as a result of that we can't
point to what the problem really
was when we had our subcommittee meeting
no one showed up so we couldn't do
anything any we couldn't get any more
information as to what the problem was
because everything online is telling us
from the kaisa family foundation and
from CMS the plan is
successful so we have no choice we were
also told by the insurance companies
that if they were forced after the
enrollment period to start covering
pre-existing conditions because remember
they are commercial providers it's not
the feds it's the commercial provider
that the rates for everyone who are
currently in those plans that are left
like I still left over from Plan F my
rates are going to go up to support that
so before we risk losing people in those
plans losing my coverage because I could
not afford it anymore we need to know a
little more information as to what the
problem was and we don't have it so
right now without any further
information and only seeing that
Medicare Advantage is actually
working uh I think we have to itl this
and I'm sorry for the long-winded
discussion but I know there's a lot of
people that have been writing all kinds
of things about but everything I've I've
received in the mail and everything that
I've heard has been based on emotional
feelings as opposed to numbers what
other the numbers of what's going on and
I I think that that's an important
distinction to make and that's where I'm
at representative mle did you
have well just just my thoughts on this
it it it looks like and and I would vote
for it by the way but reluctantly
because I think that that people made
the wrong decision up front and now
they're saying hey give me another
chance it's like if I you know somebody
buys $100,000 of life insurance the next
day they find they got a
uh a terminal illness they go back to
the insurance agent and say you owe me a
million dollars worth no you don't you
you made them mistake but I would vote
for it anyway but that's my thought can
I respond vot for the itl motion pardon
when you say vote for it I I itl it I
would actually pass pass it I would like
to address that go
ahead if you made the mistake and you
did not get the insurance correct in the
first place if you think now now let's
say my case because I've been on plan f
i there's no Plan F left there is no
plan left in standard Medicare left that
describes what the conditions were they
were talking about I got Plan F but if
you leave it it's you cannot ever get
back that's my because the plan is gone
that's my whole point but the plan is
gone it's not like it's an option
anymore it's gone well it's the plan are
Grand we have couple of grandfathers
here and grandmothers no I am a
means okay so let's change it
grandparent yes I I just want to I had
my hand up I just wanted to say that you
know I think some of the contracts that
these people had were really complicated
and they you know a lot of small print
and they didn't read it and then you
know I I I don't want to blame people
but I mean you know I don't read
contracts either a lot of them but you
know you don't read it they're
complicated and you find out that you're
in
trouble Reon
charesa so I know we had uh discussion
during the hearing a lot of discussions
on this and uh what I just heard that uh
seems like we don't have enough
information to make a determination on
this bill
so you know uh there could be options
where you can I
just you can put certain back billing or
you know I mean certain penalty or
whatever to but at least allow them to
get into what I'm trying to say is that
there there could be options there lack
of information right now so why don't we
retain this bill to discuss it further
why do you want to itl and completely
kill
it um well I guess for the simple reason
is is that
um I think we spent a lot of time in
this bill and I know myself personally I
I learned a lot um however as someone
who just got you know just turned 65 a
couple years ago and having gone through
this process um that I and and and I'll
say also for someone who's been around
long before you know in Obamacare I mean
I was around with the original in the
state of New Hampshire past 7-Eleven
with the guaranteed issue which is that
the expression a guaranteed issue that
and it was very simple when you sign
up that Advantage Plans is manage
care okay and most of us had have
managed care in this small business
Group market all right so it's not like
or even your your RIS probably even your
large employer they probably had the
same so it's not like we're learning
anything new like oh my God I didn't
understand okay it you it's not really
even even begin it's starter to know to
understand because in an advantage plan
the one that everybody signs up for in
New Hampshire which I did you know it's
uh United Healthcare with
o4 okay and they did try to sneak that
AARP name on top of it but I don't you
know I told him I want the one that
doesn't say AARP on it okay but that the
whole point of that was that no I have
no monthly
payments now this is not rocket science
I have no monthly payments now if I take
the
traditional manage care
I Medicare Plan it's not manag care it
said we you're free to choose whatever
doctor you want you're you're free to
any Hospital you are
free now but we're charging you 60 70 80
bucks a month and that doesn't even
count the dental I mean the U
pharmaceutical okay so if you actually
start adding the two of them together
you're easily up to $100 a
month so this is not rocket science one
I can go anywhere I want to go and about
I have to pay $1,200 a year yellow one's
free but you're going to have to stay in
network I don't understand people say I
don't understand it I didn't get it or
you're you're smarter than the average
person that you you figured that
out okay now we find that there are some
people who are in those Advantage Plans
and for whatever reasons they were
talked into it or they misunderstood
under or were confused or they whatever
reasons and now they want to go back to
the other
plan well it turns out it's not that
simple it turns out if you want to go
back to the the
plan they're going to ask you do you
have underlying medical conditions and
that's the reason why you want to switch
back and that is what we tried to ban
where we ban Obamacare band was that
medical records know the your your your
health uh health study so again this is
not rocket science why you have to do it
and if you do that then then there's
going to be a catch Well turns out
there's plenty of other plans plenty of
plans out there and there can be a plan
that might says okay we'll let you back
in we'll let you you really want you
really want to pay us $1,200 a year uh
we'll let you in and we won't worry
about your some won't for us the state
of New Hampshire to start mandating this
is totally
inappropriate okay so that's the point
it doesn't make any sense to this bill
this bill was is is yes they're
articulated in a problem that I never
really thought that this about that
because it seemed very straightforward
to me but they're saying that this is
important that people want us to address
this and I'm saying No this is if you if
you if this is if you don't like this
you need to call your Congressman you
need this has to be done in Washington
because this is Medicare this is not New
Hampshire health
insurance and that's the reason why I
want to kill the
bill okay so I I understand that uh you
are you are concerned about people will
people will be misusing it most of the
time there's a potential that that they
would be switching back and forth and
and no but no the actual the actual real
reason is if if we were to allow
that then we are going to bring back you
know the the uh uh with the medical
underwriting if you're going to bring
back we you say well we're going to have
Community rating so now we're going to
get into trying to change we're going to
they're going to have to change the
rates for those people who are in the
Medicare we switching back we were going
to mandate that that they have to take
you then they're going to come back and
say okay well now the rates are not
$1,200 it's now going to be 14 15 who
knows how much more they're going to add
but they'll add more and they say we
need to do that to cover these PE sikis
who are coming over who were in the
advantage plan who decided they didn't
like the doctor they were going to or
the hospital was taking care of they
want to go to see somebody else that was
out of network oh well we we if we're
going to have to pay more we want to
charge more and no it it that's a
non-starter we're not about to raise all
the people who made that decision okay
we are not going to raise their rates
simply because there are some people who
say they were they made a
mistake can I make one comment am iow to
make of course and and I made it
before as of 2020 the plan that they
wanted to go back to was the equivalent
of like Plan F and it no longer exists
there's no plan to go back to yeah and
according to CMS only 40% of people in
this country even want Medicare without
Advantage 60% of people want Medicare
Advantage when I was talking before is
that we didn't have enough information
there could very I suspect there is a
Medicare Advantage plan and if they
don't know how to find it
I don't even want to say I would help
them but there are people that could
help them figure out what plan what they
need exactly there's plenty of choices
when it comes to Advantage plan I know I
can tell you 13 different companies that
mail me in that that month and a half
you know you know starting November and
in December that you know it overwhelms
my mailbox you know like I I don't have
to worry about having starters for my
wood
stove so so chairman so basically even
if uh you're basically not giving any
provision even if they are they might be
willing to pay some penalty or some kind
of exactly they they could the penalty
would be that when they do that medical
underwriting there is a there is a
potential of being a penalty but we
can't regulate that okay but but there
but there could be option to choose by
paying penalty exactly okay and that's
all
right the motion is inexpedient to
legislate is the question clear the
role representative Puchi yes
representative
Osborne representative Ammon yes
representative Cole yes the clerk says
yes pelia is not here representative
Walsh yes representative miles yes
representative preza yes representative
Burrows yes Representatives Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Teresa yes representative
salvi yes representative hunt
yes 17 Z 17 zip all those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously okay last but not least um
House Bill 296 s um we had a
subcommittee yesterday and uh it got
changed again um and uh o overnight um I
and the right now the way the P
prospective uh amendment that we we're
theoretically could have worked on the
committee didn't have it so the
subcommittee didn't actually vote on it
Amendment but was that uh there is a
potential that there would be some kind
of Federal
grant uh that would make this paint uh
not paint excuse me make this uh tree
tree cutting or uh actually the one that
the former insurance commissioner
pointed out he says the number one
complaints the number one problem is and
this is you learn something new every
day that that um is your roof getting
blown
off okay and thatt and you say well how
do they how do you so what do you do
when you're roof and I was trying to
explain this to my wife and I said so
evidently there's a Code out there a
code book and I want I want to get a
copy of this code this is some an
insurance Regulation Code book that um
in which insurance company would say
that okay that roof that you have did
not have the proper joist nail the
things that nail that joist down on onto
the roof and that's the reason why your
roof blew off and so now whether they
you know how they handle the claim I
don't know but that they had this excuse
that that's the reason why they weren't
going to cover it and my wife
said well well did shouldn't they tell
you that ahead of time and I said well
nobody knows what's inside that roof no
one knows what those grof choices are
and so that because it it you have to
plan out from the contractor or what how
they built or whatever you don't know
this until it's over after the
incident's happen so this legislation um
that we were going to work was on on
potential that if you happen to know
that your roof is not done properly or
that you feel the roof is done properly
or you really want to cut down that tree
because you know it's going to fall down
on top of your house that this was going
to be help give you funding to to have
it removed but it was a federal Grant it
was the latest uh uh rendition of it
because the insurance companies is as
much as they want it they think it's a
great idea they certainly don't want to
pay for it they don't want to fund this
thing and that um so at this point I
think we should just retain it and um to
see see what's going on in terms of the
funding mechanism see there's some way
to resolve this but um the idea of
creating a program and saying we can
accept it we'll let that happen um
without understanding what the what the
strings attached and that I think it's
it's it's premature for us to pass this
representative spear I used to live in
Florida and uh not too far from where
Hurricane Andrew
hit and those houses that did not have
the proper roof attachments all lost
their roofs and what you do is they take
a joist and they take a cable actually
from the roof and and and pin it down to
the basement well they don't have
basements there down to the slab and
every house that did that did not lose
their roof and every house that didn't
do that lost their roofs and the house
would houses would destroyed it never
would have occurred to me that New
Hampshire has wins the likes of
Hurricane Andrew but I guess it's
possible now Washington has the biggest
wind in do they have a lot of people
living up
there we actually house it we have
people are up there all way along then
they better attach their roofs to their
basements change on the RO do you think
change on the roof to chain it down
yes no it's funny you say that because
when I had a shed put in in our summer
house in Rhode Island and which is close
to the ocean they that was one of the
things they did is they they had to
strap and strap the thing down and I
thought they were just trying to strap
down the shed but it is true that that
that cable was holding the roof down now
that I think about it see you learn
day and they have a cat
yeah yeah represent the Gibs
thank you Mr chair um I seem to have
missed something are we on 297 yes this
was a non-gain amendment that was on the
bill that and we had a hearing on the
non- gerain amendment and had a work
group and we tried our best to find a
way to do this uh mitigation plan but it
just at this point we're not ready to do
it not withstanding the representative
miles has has questions about the
underlying
bill so and that's still that is still
out there also
so yeah I mean I know you already
explained last time that why you have
combined two two bills because this bill
the name of this bill itself is very
yeah that's that is true that was that
was the original explain that and uh so
are we going to vote on retaining it
because yes we're about to vote on
retaining yes okay okay yeah because
there I think yesterday when we talked
about it there there a lot of cavard
that needs to be fixed one was like it's
a grand first first Ser basis people
might not even know about this uh and
people only who knows they'll just take
advantage others will not know and they
won't take advantage so there lot of so
you weren't too crazy about the idea in
the first place yeah so I did pick that
up in okay thank
you okay the question is to retain is
the question clear are we so this is
just uh I I move and second
representative burrow moves seconds to
retain to retain okay okay okay any
discussion on the motion see none the
clerk will call the role for the last
time for the last time okay
representative Puchi yes representative
Osborne representative Ammon yes
representative Cole yes the clerk is yes
priscilia is not here representative
Walsh yes representative miles yes
representative Pressa yes representative
burough yes representative Herbert yes
representative melier yes representative
spear yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Sullivan yes
representative terasa yes representative
zero
297 okay voted 17 to
session uh unfortunately I got to go
pick up my dog at the hospital here
you know she was she was hobbling last
night she wasn't doing well so so since
afternoon yes we do we have a bill oh
it's a liquor bill okay okay I'll be
back for that no it's just a is is it a
sub no it's a it's a it's a bill that I
forgot do we I forgot no no it's just a
hearing it's a hearing it's a hearing
yeah Rel to The Liquor Commission 529
115 what do we have
15 subcommittee yeah subte
for for banking because we menance we
already met yesterday actually don't
yeah
e
represent
Grill oh
okay so you're supposed to fill out a
pink
card
especially
she she wasn't here last
uh she's either first or second she yeah
presented yep open up the public hearing
on House Bill 529 here from the prime
sponsor representative Grill welcome to
the Commerce Committee great to be here
and uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
honorable members of the committee it is
good to be back um for those of you who
have served on this committee before or
just enjoy following the content um HB
529 might look a little bit familiar um
so the primary function of this bill is
um similar to a bill I filed last year
um it extends the last call for on
on-site alcohol service from 1 to 2:
a.m. Statewide and also enable cities
and towns to authorize a 3:00 a.m. last
call if they vote to do so um so this
year in the interest of um empowering
businesses and consumers further and
adding some flexibility room for
amendments I've added a few additional
Provisions um those include extending
the hours of inore sales from 11:45 to
1:00 a.m. allowing bartenders to refill
Growlers of beer and legalizing the sale
of to-go cocktails um so as many of you
have heard me say before uh with our
already thriving tourism industry New
Hampshire stands to benefit from
expanding opportunities for bars
restaurants shops and event venues while
encouraging people to patronize New
Hampshire businesses rather than
venturing South to the state that shall
not be named to have their fun currently
we have one of the earliest Statewide
closing times in the country most States
set a 2 a. last call including many of
our neighbors in the Northeast um laws
related to off-site or in store liquor
sales are a bit more of a patchwork how
ever New Hampshire leans on the earliest
side there too um for example Maine
allows alcohol to be sold until 1:00
a.m. um and New York allows beer to be
sold 24 hours and liquor and wine to be
sold until midnight and then lastly
regarding the concept of to-go cocktails
um this has evolved from a CO era safety
precaution to a longer term business
model and 27 States at this time have
permanently legalized to go cocktails
including Massachusetts Rhode Island
Connecticut and Maine um so
understanding that the topic can be a
bit controversial um you might wonder
why I am reintroducing this bill and
adding some additional language um
personally I think that as the Live Free
or Die state New Hampshire should be a
leader in personal freedom and this is
an area where we can easily offer
consumers more Choice um HB 529 uh will
align our liquor laws more closely with
our neighbors uh while making our state
more competitive particularly when it
comes to attracting young people to the
state although last call time is
unlikely to make or break someone's
decision to build their life in New
Hampshire it might make someone more
likely to choose New Hampshire as their
destination for a wedding or a corporate
retreat rather than Massachusetts or
Vermont um so I'm sure we all know the
adage that nothing good happens after
midnight um but personally I I also
believe that night life and social
experiences overall play an important
cultural and psychological role as Ellen
Cushing wrote in her article for the
Atlantic we need to party more only 4.1%
of Americans attended or hosted a social
event on an average weekend or holiday
in 2023 which is a 35% decrease since 20
2004 at the same time we've seen that
loneliness anxiety and depression have
increased especially among younger
adults and I am not suggesting that HB
529 is the answer to our loneliness
crisis and definitely going out to the
bar with your friends is not a
replacement for a good therapist or
medical attention um however creating
environment where people can come
together enjoy a night out and
contribute to the local economy can
definitely have a positive impact the
consumer Choice centers 20 thou uh 2023
nightlife index reported that cities
that were ranked as more welcoming
tended to have later closing times
suggesting that being open to Night Life
is a net positive for
municipalities and understandably um
you're probably concerned about the
public safety impact of more permissive
liquor laws however the data available
doesn't necessarily point to a clear
correlation between bar closing times
and unsafe behavior um in Minnesota they
found that um after extending last call
um there were a higher number of uh
people charged with DUIs however they
had also increased the police presence
leading up to this change and they did
not find a significant difference in the
blood alcohol content in those charged
before or after the policy change
suggesting that it was the um the
benefit of the the proactive policing
more so than a change in behavior um a
2002 study also found that drunk driving
rates were more closely correlated with
the number of restaurants in an area but
not bars um and most significantly um we
saw that drunk driving increase during
covid when bars and restaurants were
closed all together um and anecdotally
I've heard from friends in the bar and
restaurant industry that when last call
time is earlier um patrons can sometimes
feel the pressure to drink more alcohol
more quickly in order to beat the clock
where when um they expect the bar to be
open later they might Pace themselves
more so um not a scientific stat but um
it kind of indicates that looking at the
research together um unsafe drinking
behaviors are more closely related to
more complex social and personal factors
um versus just last call time in itself
um to-go drinks also don't seem to be
associated with clear public saf risks
um I've included some research on your
desk for your um your review but um in
2023 the Virginia Alcohol Beverage
Control Authority reported that
compliance with underage drinking laws
was similar for venue selling tog go
cocktails and traditional brick-and
morar restaurants um the problematic
factor in terms of compliance was
third-party delivery services but even
then they improved their compliance in
2024 to over
90% um states that allowed alcohol
delivery during the pandemic also
reported decreases in underage drinking
as well as a lower rise in pandemic era
drinking rates compared to those that
did not again suggesting that there's
more deeper factors at play than um the
availability of these Services um so
taking uh together this data does not
show a clear relationship between
policies such as later last call times
or tog go cocktails and rates of drunk
driving um under HB 529 venues will
still be responsible for ensuring their
customer sa safety including not over
serving not letting people drive home
who are drinking um and not serving min
um so police are still empowered to
enforce laws to protect their community
and with so many options available for
ride sharing as well as the growth and
educational campaigns um spreading
awareness of the risks of problem
drinking there's simply no reason or
excuse to engage in unsafe ilal Behavior
whether it's 1:00 a. 2 am. 3: a.m. it
just shouldn't be happening at any time
um however with that in mind um again I
did intend for this bill to be more
flexible I'm definitely open to amending
this bill to um remove Parts add Parts
addressing issues such as law
enforcement funding and I am 100% open
to any suggestions from committee
members or the community to um make any
changes to um potentially address some
of those concerns um so essentially this
bill is about Choice um it will expand
Commerce options for businesses while
get giving cities more options to meet
the needs of their residents um and if a
business owner doesn't want to stay open
that late or participate in serving to
go cocktails they won't be required to
HB 529 simply offers more options to
help expand the economy and let
consumers enjoy their time in New
questions uh Jo my memory what did we do
with this bill before or some of these
items here they do look familiar I just
don't remember what we did with them
yeah so my my original bill was um just
the extension of hours of sale um that
passed the house last session but um our
friends on the other side of the wall um
disagreed with the house position so
what did we end up passing last year um
I believe it was extension of last call
I think possibly store sales might have
been included on or off premise I think
on premise on Prem at least so you
didn't have on off premise okay just on
premise yes and we went from the current
laws one to two yes and that's all we
did and and they still the Senate killed
it um well it also added municipalities
could vote till extens we the municipal
yeah okay so that that's the one that's
what we did before and we we did pass
that yes so I figured for this year you
know if the other body is more open to
in store sales only extending that to 1:
a.m. but not off premises we can amend
as needed I figured I'd start a little
bigger and then we can Whittle things
down as um you know as we work through
that process but the on premise last
call sale um did pass this
body perfect do we have any questions on
what what's the date of that so we make
sure we we hit that date again uh that
was March 28th last year okay
representative bar yes thanks for taking
my question I'm reading here about um
that they can't deliver to uh College
University or school what if the
individual um placing the orders over
21 yeah that's a great question um so
again I definitely believe in you know
the freedom of students who are over 21
um my my thinking there was you know
just thinking about risks and ways we
can mitigate that risk knowing that
there are additional safety concerns
with to- Go cocktails I figure you know
creating an environment where providing
a drink to someone underage is less
likely to happen is probably a safer bet
um and obviously if a student is living
off campus there um they're more than
welcome to participate but it's more
about risk mitigation versus um trying
to limit options followup and obviously
if somebody's living in their own house
or off campus that's fine but I mean I
don't know what they legality it is of
saying that you're not going to deliver
I I know some college campuses say no no
liquor but if somebody's L over 21 and
on campus can we can we is it legal to
do that I guess is the question I don't
have that answer for you off the top of
my head I'm I'm happy to look into it um
and personally I'm on I'm on the same
page as you know people should have that
option I just um in the interest of kind
of mitigating some of that risk of
enabling that behavior sure thank you
well saying on that
subject because I see the word liquor
all dropped in
here um my memory and I'm reading the
statue so is that whatever got
delivered was in a prepackaged
bottle are you when you say liquor here
were you thinking that
a on premise lensey is now going to sell
a full bottle of liquor
or were you thinking a pre-made
drink um so I my intention was a
pre-made drink um in the language I
believe I included um some sort of
branded cup or sealed cup um making that
change um if that's not in there I'm
happy to take another look at that but
the intention was for it to be a tog go
cocktail versus a uh delivery bottle of
inally did not want to make that legal
when we allow delivery of alcohol that
was intent itional that yeah the
intention was a mixed cocktail we don't
know what's in that mixed cocktail we
don't you know that where if it's a
preix m you know when there are you know
you can buy premixed liquor from the
liquor
store but it at the alcohol level is
going to be a higher level than what
it's available on the off- premise
license C so we don't have liquor stores
that are
open very late
so that that ain't happening in New
Hampshire because they're not open to
sell a premix drink so your your
intention was that you were thinking
that and I know that some states did
pass this that you they make a drink in
a and and put it in a container and you
know you can have that Margarita to go
and but that
it's it's a in a container but it's not
a sealed container nor put together
other than put together by the on
premise license heat yeah the intention
and again I'm happy to help clean up the
language if that's a little fuzzy um but
my my intent was similar to the co model
um you know you're for example let's say
you're getting um you know taco night to
go and you want to get a couple of
margaritas and you're going to drink and
eat your Mar your tacos and your
margaritas at home watching a movie to
you get no we didn't let you do that you
had to buy the premix one that was
made that you can buy in the off-
premise licy had a premix now some on
premise lenes could have it could have
the you know the premix margarita mix I
don't know how many did that probably
not too many but that because the end of
the day that you know they had to buy
the one that was the lower alcohol
content in an op in here in Co in New
Hampshire unlike maybe other states
the intention was more for like you
could order the drink that you would eat
or drink in the in the restaurant to go
um with your takeout food um and I I
know that has been done in other states
um again if the language for for this is
unclear I'm happy to work on that to
clarify fair enough thank you oh we do
have another question representative
pusk yes thank you for taking my
question representative uh relative to
section one hours of sales has anybody
done a cost benefit
analysis that would justify an
establishment being open and what would
the cost be and how much profit they
would assume
uh I just that's just a business
question that's what I'm asking no I
think that's a great question um so
there hasn't been any formal studies
that I could find um in New Hampshire
specifically um it's tough Countrywide
because there is such a patchwork of
different laws you know for example in
in New York or Massachusetts the last
call is later but it's been later for
quite some time so it would be hard to
kind of make that comparison looking
back I think that would definitely be
helpful research to to undertake and I
think um again I I've heard anecdotally
you know mix things from businesses some
some people say like yeah we'd love to
work later get get more tips get more
more profit others say this wouldn't
apply to my business I wouldn't be
interested in staying open that later so
it is again intended to have the
flexibility not the requirement but I
think it would be interesting to see um
maybe a pilot test I mean I'd certainly
love to
see oh he's got his face in his hands
already um but I I think it would be
interesting to see some uh some Topline
data digging into those numbers um and
um and doing that sort of formal market
analysis further question you me thank
you Mr chair uh do you know of any
states which have done this have
extended their hours really recently
that might give us some kind of an
indication as to a cost benefit analysis
that a state maybe it's done within the
past two or three years to see what they
have and it would help justify uh the
restaurant associations to look at this
in a maybe more favorable
manner um that is a great question um
I'll take that as a follow-up and I'll
um do some digging there and get back to
you great repres sen
wals thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um in your
section about allows on premises
licenses to deliver liquor to customers
who order a meal I does that include
like a door
Dash um Service as well and would they
have to verify that the person getting
the drink is over
21 um so my intention was to only
allowed the vendor the restaurants or or
owners themselves to be in charge of
that delivery um I think once you get
into the third party delivery there's a
lot more problematic data in terms of
compliance um generally speaking from
what I saw from the research from
Virginia unfortunately my printer ran
out of ink but there's a couple of
copies up with representative post um
the the compliance rates in terms of
verifying age was um equivalent to on
premises sales from brick and morar
restaurants for um delivery managed by
the restaurants themselves but the
compliance was lower for those
thirdparty vendors so my intention um
with this language was to limit those
delivery services to the um the
restaurant owners and Proprietors
themselves rather than getting into that
kind of murky territory I feel like
again it it opens it up to more risk and
yeah it they are supposed to check IDs
um that that's the law they're required
to but I think there's so much great
area and kind of less sort of so you
just a you know this statue which is
everything is current law other than the
word liquor is you can see that it it
has to be the restaurant licy and
they're going to get another extra for
an extra
$250 they get a delivery
license and yes that that licy that
restaurant is responsible for the
getting the ID and making sure the
delivery but under our current statute
no door Dash is not permitted right okay
and followup for the question thank you
so is it limited one per person I was
trying to see where it said that here um
I didn't include any specific language
um but that could be a good potential
Amendment again to help mitigate that
risk further um again I try I tried to
strike the balance between okay the the
risk management and harm reduction and
uh just
Margaritas I don't know maybe a limit a
limit of some sort
maybe no I think I think that's a good
question and we intentionally did not
put a number in the
spear okay representa this kind of a
comment and I I guess it's a question of
how it would fit
in I've been approached by a a number of
restaurants in in Nashua downtown Nashua
that have asked for the ability because
people come and they take food out MH
the ability to also provide however many
meals they're sending out at that time
you know people come in and pick it up
to have various drinks go with those
meals in some kind of a little renewable
kind of thing this seems to be something
that the restaurants seem to want and
believe it or not I usually
but it would be if you if you're going
to start considering any limits it would
seem to me it depends on how many meals
are being delivered I mean I don't
see you know somebody's ordering five
meals to take out you don't want to
limit it to one
drink just a
thought we did not the legislation the
current statute right now we have no
limits on how much can be delivered yeah
and and it seems to be something
restaurants Chinese meals you have lots
of Entre and doesn't tell you how many
people are actually sharing it it
doesn't and and I'm fine with no limit I
have no problem with that it's just that
it's interesting that the bill came up
at a time when restaurants have actually
approached me to ask if we could do
something like this right so apparently
it's something that so there there is a
demand for us to pass
something just trying to help the people
out represent
Gibbs thank you Mr chair just to follow
up on the earlier question the the
intent is that the the delivery would
have to be made by somebody who works at
the restaurant not by a third party
that's correct so you wouldn't have an
unknown person working for one of these
companies come in and deliver it to
someone else it would need to be someone
from the restaurant taking the food to
the um customer's home checking their ID
making sure that they're of age um not
the third party Services now thank
you thank you very much thank you uh
Cher will call on uh Karen Benfield from
stay work play New
part thank you
thank you so much uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
record again my name is Karen Benfield
I'm the executive director at State work
play New Hampshire a nonprofit dedicated
to attracting and retaining young people
here in our state um I am here in
support of HB 529 because we need to be
thinking not just about what brings
young people to New Hampshire but what
keeps them here as well New Hampshire is
facing a demographic crisis as um many
of us here understand um our Workforce
is a in our population of young workers
is shrinking um and we're competing with
neighboring states that offer more
Dynamic accessible and engaging social
environments the re the reality is is
that a thriving night life and
Hospitality scene matters to young
people when deciding where to live work
and build their future our 2023 quality
of life survey uh shows that no uh the
night life and lack of social scene here
in New Hampshire is actually the second
biggest reason why young people choose
to leave New Hampshire uh right behind
cost of living which uh can come as a
shock it was actually shocking to me to
to learn that um that actually shares a
very clear message um we're not just
competing on jobs and housing with our
neighboring states we're also competing
on quality of life as well HB 529 is a
step in the right direction it expands
sales uh sales hours allowing alcohol
delivery with meals and support small
businesses with refillable beer sales um
that uh and these aren't uh just policy
tweaks um they're ways to also meet
young people where they are whether it's
after hours at home or on the go uh
young people just want the same
conveniences and experiences that they
can find in other states this bill
doesn't Force businesses to change but
it creates the space for them to adapt
and evolve on their terms in ways that
make sense for their communities and
that flexibility matters young young
people aren't just looking for a
paycheck when deciding where to set
Roots they're looking for places to
gather to connect and feel like they're
amongst peers in the second oldest state
in the country every opportunity to
create spaces for young people matters
when we look to retain uh our Workforce
this isn't just about staying
competitive it's also about keeping the
Next Generation right here in the
granite state so uh I urge you to
support HB 529 and take a step forward
um for a more vibrant and attractive
happy to take questions evidently there
aren't any
sorry okay uh this I've never seen a
card like this
before some's a little schizophrenic
today he opposes it and supports it so
minutes good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
Mike Summers president CEO of the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association and I'm glad you got a kick
out of that I did it entirely for your
purpose so um so we're a little bit
conflicted on this bill obviously
there's three components to the bill as
were was outlined by the sponsor uh one
we don't like one we are kind of meh on
and the third one we really like so
that's hence the reason for the kind of
oppose and support So in in order of uh
sections in the bill obviously the
extension of hours we have la had a
problem with that um frankly we think
that right now with the local option to
be able to go to 2: a.m. is probably
sufficient um and if you will note uh
there's only one or two uh jurisdictions
in the state of New Hampshire that have
actually taken that on which means that
there are is almost nobody in the
industry that's actually asking for this
and I don't see a crowd behind us here
in support of uh changing the hours so
um I'll just start with that um but the
biggest issue frankly in the extension
of hours for our industry currently is
we we don't have enough staff we don't
have enough staff to man the hours if
you notice there's a lot of restaurants
that no longer do lunches they close at
9:30 or 10:00 it's not because it you
know the owners are tired want to go
home we don't have staff we don't have
bartenders that will work those kinds of
hours um and more and more restaurants
are literally Clos two days a week
because then they have like one set
staff and they all work the same chefs
um moving on to this section two of the
bill the on- premise delivery on premise
lies for mixed drinks we do like this
provision um as was mentioned in
testimony this has been enacted in 27
States uh it is a kind of a remnant of
the covid era um we were successful in
working with the legislature a few years
ago or a couple years ago after the uh
pandemic to um uh codify and statute
that you know um uh beer and wine to go
um was was allowed um the structure of
that has worked out very nicely for some
folks but there are uh businesses that
have certainly solicited me uh looking
for us to extend it to mixed drinks as
well couple couple of concerns though
where I hope to work with the
subcommittee on the language we would be
interested to see that there's some
language around how the container must
be sealed for transportation right
because you don't necessarily want
somebody who's getting a tog go cocktail
necessarily stepping out uh and taking a
good swill off it whilst they're on the
driving home so I think we have to have
some sort of control in place there and
I would suspect you're going to hear
that from the looking commission as well
um the second piece is um some
limitation on the ABV
because the currently the way is drafted
you could really just fill up a you know
a yeti with you know a bottle of vodka
right awesome that's a mixed drink for
sure but I I I don't know that that's
necessarily responsible service so I
think we would probably wouldn't that be
a
martini be a very large Martini uh and I
think most of our our members anyway
have a two Martini limit because um gets
a little ugly after that so we would uh
we we would want to work with the
subcommittee around some some additional
controls in that space But ultimately in
concept we love it um we appreciate the
fact that this drafting of the Lang
legislation does keep that it has to be
a W2 employee of the business that does
the delivery it maintains that the
person receiving the alcohol has
obviously has to be 21 and has to sign a
receipt to the states that fact so all
of those controls there I think are
great um and and we're supportive of
that and then the third part of this
bill um the on premise licenses to uh
fill refill refillable refillable
containers not really spefic specific on
what sorts of containers are we talking
like a 5 gallon bucket what are we
talking about here assume it's a growler
well but I I okay so assuming it's a
growa but that doesn't necessarily say
that in here so this could be anything
this could be a Yeti uh it could be a
old milk jug I mean there's no real
control on what that might be um frankly
I don't think our industry really cares
about this again um I'm not sure too
many people are going to necessarily
sell beer this way um because if we're
selling it at our what we would normally
sell a beer over the bar it would be
exorbitantly expensive versus just
purchasing you know a case of beer or
something at the store so um again we're
a little ambivalent on section three so
with that I will end and I happy to try
to answer any
questions
perfect representa
Kips thank you Mr chair just out of
curiosity in reference to Containers
what is a
yeti uh so it's anything from a small
tumbler to a very large tumbler they're
very well insulated so it keeps you
drink cold for a very long time no
that's Stanley that's not a Yeti that's
a Stan and I can tell that all the way
back here I have a Yeti that's it's this
big it literally holds two cocktails and
it keeps it cold for
hours yes it many sizes yes and they
have really nice coolers too but I can't
afford and they do
coolers represented
Sullivan thank you so you mentioned one
of the when you were opposed to the
extended hours part you mentioned that
one of the problems is is Staffing but
nobody would be required to stay open
until two F another staff correct again
the way the way our organization works
we work with the government Affairs
committee and then we that they make a
recommendation to the board of directors
we solicit information from a lot of
members this is what they are telling us
please don't do this we don't want to
have to deal with it um and then I you
know we do hear from some though it's
it's it's a handful but they're like you
know what's it going to do to policing
in our in our town right because now
You' essentially taken what would be the
problem hours of you know midnight to
one now now becomes midnight to
potentially 3:00 a.m. and what does that
do for policing at the local level so um
you again I just I'm sharing with you
what what I'm been asked to share with
you which is that they don't like it
happen thank you very much thank
you okay uh oh we got one more before
Mark are you going to you're going to
wrap it up okay CJ Haynes from the New
Association welcome back to the Congress
committee thank you for having me Mr
chair and members of the committee I am
C.J Haynes I am the executive director
of the New Hampshire Brewers Association
I currently represent nearly 80
breweries across the state of New
Hampshire and as of now we are currently
in opposition of this bill as it is
written specifically regarding the
refillable container section um part of
this has to do with a growing concern
that our members have had throughout the
years is that they if an on premise
account were to fill their product in a
container then it becomes
retail that would directly compete with
their retail sales additionally it would
also concern them about the sanitation
of what is being filled so if a growler
comes in there's nothing to say that
that Growler is clean
sanitized you could bring in anybody's
you could bring in the
yeti um and have that filled and so the
breweries are concerned about the
quality of the product that would go
into that refillable container and once
it goes into that refillable container
it becomes packaged Goods therefore it's
retail so therefore they have no control
over what is being sold as retail and
they feel as manufacturers that they
should be the sole responsible entity
for packaging their goods
uh additionally there's concerns that
there's no additional licensing fees
required for this where breweries do
have additional licenses they have their
manufacturing license they have a
restaurant on premise license they have
a retail outlet location license that
they need to acquire for this so we
would be asking for parody there there's
also a delivery license fee
that's
$250 the other stipulation is that
currently as this is written it says
that there is no food requirement so
what is to stop somebody from coming in
Billing a Growler and leaving without
food in essence that is to go purchasing
at retail not at a restaurant therefore
the retail Service delivery says that
food must be purchased with the alcohol
this would allow for them to just
purchase alcohol and take it to go uh
additionally we aside from that there's
no way for a brewery to opt out of that
there's no Clause that says that the
brewery can decide that they do not want
their product to be repackaged so
there's concerns for there and other
than that there's also no specifications
for any off- premise consumption only in
the language so that means somebody
could essentially fill a growler on site
and then go sit at a picnic table at the
restaurant and drink that entire
Growler and those are our concerns how
what's hell that different than just
getting a picture of
beer it's not but it's considered retail
so therefore there would be no rooms and
retail
really once it becomes r i c this whole
statute that everything that was done
under the statue was was uh rooms and
meals no because if it's packaged Goods
it becomes retail product and therefore
retail would not be taxed well you're
just throwing a curve I have never
thought about m
okay CU I'm pretty sure if we look at
the current statue now everything that
goes out is treated as rooms and
meals even though it's in a bottle you
know seal bottle wi wine you buy a wine
bottle of wine at at a restaurant and
and use this delivery system you're
right Mike aren't you guys charging
rooms and you don't know maybe
we don't know okay but technically
they're
not but right now this would stipulate
that no food is required for the
purchase of this because it is
written
uh I've never thought of it that way but
that's interesting that's interesting
okay and I'm happy to answer any
questions and on the other factors we
have no opposition to the others as they
are currently written um it was just the
third okay thank
you yes representative thank you I just
have a clarification question to
whomever can answer it when you go to
the grocery store and you buy one of
their packaged meals you get you get
charged a rooms of meals tax so why
wouldn't if a restaurant is providing
the same thing
and a it's a drink too with it why would
that not get charged rooms and meals I I
I mean we made I know that in terms of
we had the big issue with the the
Brewers that when they were pouring beer
and selling it inside the beer
establishment there was some question
whether that was room's meals but in
that case that they're pouring it and
there's it's an open container so yes
room and meals you you guys collect
rooms and meals tax not on Growlers
because they're consider on Growlers
because the assumption is they're
capping it and walking out correct but
if it's a glass correct or if I don't
know if you sell pictures yep and so
those are rooms and meals because it's
container chair because the beer and
right right no I see that grocery St
be if if it's a well so that's I'm
saying it's it if you take the the rest
of the statute the question is if the
margarita was made at a
restaurant therefore it should be rooms
and meals and whereas again we're
talking about uh um in this case this
was clearly I thought it was a growler I
that was the other concern we had is
there was no stipulation to me when I
read that it was a red Growler to me but
but but um but you know in terms of a
refillable container that could be a
pitcher so somebody can walk in with a
pitcher and say I'm I'm going to take it
away and and it's not it doesn't say it
had to be
resalable refillable
container regardless yeah so it doesn't
doesn't say it had to be sealed under
that under that particular paragraph
correct I will also add the majority of
breweries no longer fill Growlers based
on Growlers are really on their way out
that's the original grower bille yes we
we used to have we used to have another
member of this committee who would who
went through the whole thing about how
how the why it was called a growler is
burp yeah okay thank you thank you all
good afternoon Mr chairman committee
members for the record uh Chief Mark
armaganian uh director of liquor
enforcement and Licensing with me here
today is Deputy Chief Danielle Elston uh
deputy director of the same entity um I
think the better way for me to take uh
representative Grill's uh bill and we
have spoken at at quite extent on some
of the uh different things that are in
this bill um there are three items in
this bill as you already know um and if
I'm not mistaken Growers was your bill
it represent tur that's already
passed we passed the grower bill yeah
last year last year I thought we
did okay for manufacturers only not for
retail yeah no it was only for the
beverage manufacturers um so I think
it's better for me to go through this
that way and then kind of the extra
stuff that's on it and I'll do it
quickly for you um hours of service um
like last year we look at that as an
unfunded mandate I totally re realize
that
we're there is a movement to start
deregulating some of the restrictions
that are on um I'm not going to give you
my opinion on how that is right now I
think I'll be given opportunities later
on in the session to talk about that uh
but right now um we're looking at this
and the other law enforcement groups at
like the Chiefs um uh the Police
Association I'm sure the Troopers
Association will all look at this as an
unfunded mandate right now uh we did
some quick math this morning just taking
the middle of the road of one of our
investigators and right now our
investigators are at the max of what
statistically and nationally uh they
could handle as far as establishments
that they cover out the 6400 uh lenses
that we have so with the group that we
have right now we're looking at almost a
quarter of a million dollar over what we
spend right now in regulating the
industry
it's about uh
221 uh 29,000 two
$230,000 a year just for three extra
days uh the days of the weekend Friday
Saturday Sunday or Thursday Friday
Saturday um so right there uh as you
know we've always been fiscally
responsible um we see uh our next the
next phase of this which is uh extension
of our
that is something that can be done right
now uh we talked about that last year
also right now we have three
establishments out of
our three yeah three jurisdictions but
uh how many on premise
lenses uh we have a total of of that
that are actually asking for an
extension of service hours uh one being
uh nashwa the the other being lonia and
what's our third one Berlin so so um we
don't see that as an issue that the
industry is asking for readily right now
nobody has come to us requesting this uh
and quite frankly if they did request it
if we saw an overabundance of requests
on this it would be something we were we
would message to your group about to
possibly come up with legisl of our own
to accommodate but we're not seeing that
um liquor to go um as you know uh during
uh the the nucleus or the the heart of
the covid year um we were uh contacted
by Governor sununu's office during that
time uh we were asked how we could jump
start the industry uh we uh pushed
forward to go uh um that was quite
successful but it was to go in original
manufactured containers so we knew what
the ABV was on that they were the
Integrity of the uh the sealed product
was there so we knew that we would not
um uh we would not Infiltrate The the
nucleus of the car operating cars and
and open containers and all that stuff
that you've just brought up so so the
biggest thing when it comes to liquor to
go and and specifically spirits to go uh
mixed drinks is that we don't know what
the ABV is in that container there's no
way for us to check it um so now let's
you know we talked about Margaritas Jin
and tonics whatever you want to let's
talk scorpion bowls let's talk Long
Island Iced Tea let's talk my ties let's
talk
the St the the God forbid a negative
incident happens in the already high
number of negative incident on our
highways goes even higher and we end up
being the joke of the whole nation
because our numbers are that high so I
get and I'm one of those guys I've I've
leaned a lot to relaxing regulation as
you know over the eight years these
hitting these three point points is only
going to create a a problem for all of
us and a problem with our with our
safety in our communities we only
regulate to the level of community and
Industry Safety we do not over regulate
we have promised that to you guys uh
from day one eight years ago when this
new Administration came in and we have
guard rails up to make sure that we we
stay within that um we see this as as a
very negative I get the fun factor of
all that I have kids in this age group
um I know what they're doing what
they're not the age group that has
become of drinking age recently is not
drinking they're going and using other
elements um that this state has chosen
not to go in that direction right now
you're going out of
state so thank God that my kids
personally have NCAA uh sport uh
regulations and and other things that
keep them preclude them from uh from
doing nefarious things so um but but
that that is in a nutshell what we're
looking at right now uh Danielle has
some technical features that she'd like
to talk about um but we see this as
stuff that we've already touched upon
and do um and other things that we uh
have negative uh information on that we
would like to not to see in happen in
this state so dang
it thank you um CDC produces a community
guide they publish it regularly um this
is distributed through the national
alcohol and Beverage Control Association
uh their Community guide uh concludes
that every additional two hours of
alcohol sales was associated with an
increase of violence uh last there there
was a study group who did also did a um
study on um the increase in hours of
alcohol sale and they also concluded
that there is an increase of violence
associated with um the increase in hours
of sale with alcohol um as the chief
said we have three jurisdictions who
have taken right now you can by law
serve till two if your jurisdiction
adopts that there's three that have done
it NASA has only allowed it for
charitable gaming establishments Bonia
only allows it for the where's Beach
location and Berlin has uh they were the
first ones to pass it um they have a
very small amount of on sale licenses
and from our um
enforcement uh surveillance that we've
seen that uh many of them aren't even
utilizing the um staying open after
after 1:00 a.m. in terms of the delivery
um right now we have 2100 uh lies who
are eligible for the um delivery and
curb side of beer and wine only 37 have
um used that license last year we
received a grant to do some data
collection on the restaurant delivery um
of those 37 uh roughly 10 to 12 were not
even utilizing curbside delivery um
curbside pickup or delivery um and we
did have a 22% failure rate of those 37
license establishments that were um
utilizing the restaurant delivery when
it came to uh selling to
miners um so again in terms of of those
licens to do is a small amount that are
actually um even utilizing the the
delivery of beer and wine we don't allow
third party delivery in the state um I
don't think you want to see the
statistics on the rest of the states
that have allowed the third party
delivery so uh we support the W2
employee um If This Were to pass and um
as many others said in terms of the
refillable containers it doesn't specify
what that container would be so um and
there is no food requirement for that so
yes you could walk as written right now
you could walk in with any type form of
tog go cup or you could bring in your
coffee cup and have that filled with
go represent Amon than you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony you talk
about third party delivery I I was in
Texas a few months ago and I want a door
dash for my my little hotel room and I
noticed there was an option for liquor
and it had you know all the drinks that
you could uh imagine they don't have
state stores there they have retail
liquor establishments um but I think the
procedure was they check your ID before
they hand it over to you so you know
door Dash is a big company Uber Eats
they're big companies it seems like in
other states they already have this uh
facility for policing the delivery um is
that something that we could consider
here that that might push us in that
direction start thank you for your
question representative um
so first uh those entities are not
lenses so there's no way to hold them
accountable uh if they don't there is
data out there that these entities are
not doing as you have stated they're not
checking those IDs and and we're having
alcohol being or they having I should
say alcohol being shipped to or
delivered to schools colleges to that
vulnerable age group that isn't of age
to drink um uh and and thus far um we
haven't seen anything positive we were
actually the ones that asked in that
bill to have a W2 employee of of the
establishment not by
Statute so
anything so yes um Nationwide we um
we're actually part of a group called
The National liquor law um enforcement
Association and um that since covid when
a lot of these groups pass it that this
has been the Hot Topic at um throughout
the group and um the enforcement
challenges and uh High failure rates of
the third party delivery um entities
alcohol okay oh represent
thank you thank you for taking my
question um at the beginning you
referred to an unfunded mandate could
you explain what you meant by that so in
appropriation if we're talking a quarter
of a million dollars and that was just
quick math that we did this morning
representative and thank you for your
good to see you great for your uh thank
you for your uh question
um that is a quarter of a million
dollars that we haven't budgeted for for
enforcement action uh to come up into
the next half of this uh this coming
fiscal so right now where we're all
being asked to give back more than to
move forward and that the money is flat
right now as far as alcohol sales are
concerned we look at this as being an
expenditure that really isn't necessary
right now because we don't have the um
the
the asking to do this uh our
establishments can ask to do this right
now and they're not asking us to do this
further question me inquire thank you um
right so my question is we heard from
the Restaurant Association that no one
wants to stay open uh you're uh
affirming that no one wants to stay open
so where does the additional enforcement
cost come into play it would be there
just because we would have to be out for
those purposes we couldn't tell if one
establishment stays open in the whole
state we're going to have to keep people
out for that time we can't just say okay
we're going to let that one person stay
open and there's no
oversight um and whether that it's just
regulating or or inspecting that
establishment or making sure that
establishment is doing right uh by by
the laws it it can go even more so if
there is a negative incident that comes
out of that establishment and let's say
it's a fatal crash State Police right
now calls us to do that part of the
investigation uh as it relates to our
licensed establishment uh just because
we can navigate
um a lot better A lot more fluid through
those establishments than they can um so
so we look at this as as I said we look
at it as a dollars and cents item
um uh that the money isn't there right
now to do this um we also look at it as
you're you're giving more time for
people to drink or consume alcohol so
where where it has been testified that
the positive is or the negative is
you're pushing because the the
bookmarker or or the guard rails on the
end time and people are drinking quicker
I would say you're giving them more time
to drink more alcohol so conversely it's
just given more time to consume more to
push your own personal uh blood alcohol
volume up higher which is going to
create the possibility of more negative
incidents on the on the street on the
highways whether they're DWI and nothing
happens out of it other than somebody's
arrested for DWI or a God forbid a crash
happens which none of want to see so I
get where this is going and and I get
where where you're leaning toward but at
the end of the day I in my own view I
don't see the positives outweighing the
negatives here just for informational
purposes further question you may
inquire um so do you think that uh
license fees should be uh based on hours
of operation then if uh if if that's
there's a correlation with enforcement
costs um so thank you for your question
again representative I I first of all
that has always been something that is
is regulated by your group um you this
group sets the the license fees um the
last time that was done is in I think if
I remember what Aiden and I spoke about
a couple weeks ago was probably 199
um but I will say that every time that
we've had smaller items like one license
fee that needed to be increased it was
always frowned upon um but um you know
that we would support and as far as fees
are concerned we would support anything
forward you all said or another question
I got another one keep goingt different
topic so on the um on the Togo beverages
which I don't think makes sense to call
them too beverages more like delivery
beverages um you mentioned being
concerned about uh Highway incidents yep
and yes don't you think though that by
delivering the beverages to the home
that we would be reducing Highway
incidences as opposed to people having
to leave their home go to the bar drink
and then drive home well it they aren't
the same delivery is different than to
go and they the to go
delivery um I don't I don't
see I don't see what I do see is we have
liquor going out the door that we don't
know what the ABV is that that's my
concern with that if it was liquor in a
in a what we call an RTD a ready to
drink like the canned Jack dangels and
Coke
uh not to pick on one but but that seems
an obvious one um those are okay to go
out the door because we the the ABV is
on them the amount of uh uh ounces per
can are on them um and the Integrity of
the top is is sealed um it's when you
get into a circumstance that you have a
cup as as uh I don't know which one if
you have it uh I'm going to say it's
represent of was um uh there's no way to
seal that at which time if you're if
you're to go in the to go portion you
can easily sip out of that like you
would sip out of whatever iced tea or
coffee that's in it um that would cause
a negative a negative instance but um at
the same time if you're delivering that
again if it's in a container that is is
sealed I and that means you could
actually make it because there are
crowlers out there and I call them
crowlers not Growlers there are crawlers
out there canned larger volume um uh
containers that you could put a beverage
in two and seal it up but it's it's
literally about how you seal that
container and and sealing that container
would be near to Impossible especially
talking to uh our neighbors uh ma uh
Vermont did it Vermont's trying to
repeal it right now and Maine did it
also and both of them had very negative
outcomes did you
want um the statute I don't mean to I
can
see um this would allow liquor to go as
takeout too the second part of the
statute allows uh this to be if this is
delivery and curbside pickup oh okay um
so this would allow liquor at curbside
if
um in terms of the way we wrote the
statute before which was trans it was
the Beverages and
wine and I don't see us exactly writing
in the ready to go packaging there's
part of the there's a significant amount
of the law that's missing rules exactly
so if we were just to drop this word
leave this word liquor in there
then um it could still be still the
ready to go right because Jose Cuervo
makes a margarita in a in a
container there are there are some you
know alcohol you know liquor drinks you
know like you say that you know like the
the uh the the Jim Beam and Coke in the
six to eight percentage AB in the
beverage level but I'm saying saying I
in if I go into the state liquor
store and anheiser bush has got what's
the company
cutwater cutwater has uh margar they
have a margarita that's
12% so
theoretically those products if we just
add this liquor in here I would assume
that all we're doing is allowing those
products to then be sold at a off-
premise license
E I think the ex me on premise license e
right and would you would be okay with
that right Mike when you want to to sell
a cut waterer cut waterer already made
drink or do you really is it really
drink you want to have some nice you
know you you don't want cheap Jose quvo
a right so that that that would that
would be where our conf where this this
yeah yeah but again we don't have any
control over how how how generous the
bartender was when he made
it that's giv and and and as far as I'm
concerned frankly if if we are leaving
to that I I'm not sure I want to exempt
them from the rooms and meals cuz you're
yeah okay we got some work on this one
okay represent of Sullivan and then Gibs
um excuse me so you said that you
wouldn't you haven't been hearing a lot
from people or your members whatever not
members I guess but you haven't been
getting a lot of requests for 2 a.m. but
would those requests come to you because
my understanding is that it would go to
the town body first and maybe they just
haven't gotten to you and also how well
educated are people and this is like a
genuine question because my experience
has been that many people don't know
that 2 a.m. is even legal in New
Hampshire under the conditions that we
currently have just from casual talking
with people around the state who run
these sorts of establishments and so I'm
just curious a if you guys have any idea
of how well people are informed of the
current law and B why would you guys be
the ones hearing about it if it needs to
start at the local level first so um so
yes they can change for a flat out
extension of the service hours it needs
to be done to the local level we do
allow um extensions of service hours um
special requests to come
um so we have lenses who request it for
example like um New Year's Eve they'll
submit requests to extend their hours
later if they're hosting a New Year's
Eve party things like that um we don't
get a significant amount I would say we
get less than 20 a year um for
individual lenses to extend their hours
for particular events in terms of the
knowledge that people have of these laws
um we we um discussed the hours of sale
in our training um in terms of the full
we have the full statute and all the
training as to um what the hours of sale
are and the we again we we show the full
statute so they do see it um it's not
something we message out regularly so I
can't speak to you know collectively as
a whole what the industry knows of it
but they they are exposed to it in their
initial training and
followup um okay so you're saying that
that you guys it doesn't have to go
through a town in order to get like a
special like so if I want to have a s if
I was a bar owner I want to have a St
Patrick's Day party and have it be open
till 2 I could actually have you guys
approve that for one day yep gotcha y we
do we always seek local buyin for that
meaning we'll reach out to the local
municipality just in case you know we
don't know we don't always know what
problems they're having with the
licensed establishments right away so we
do seek local buying from it as long as
the local municipality doesn't approve
to that extension of service then we'll
approve thata
thanks pretty good huh
friendly service there at the Liquor
Commission okay represent
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for coming to testify today um Chief
uh over over jiman am I pronouncing that
correctly yes okay great um you
mentioned that it's impossible to seal
the top of a cup um but isn't it isn't
it in fact possible to seal a cup and
the Reon reason that I mentioned this is
that yesterday I went to a counter resta
Resturant and ordered a boba tea uh
which was made there and then given to
me and the top of that cup was sealed so
tightly that the um person from behind
the counter had to come over and help me
struggle to get my my um straw into the
cup um so I have personally encountered
cups that were
sealed I'm not familiar I am familiar
with Boba um
uh but I'm not familiar with the cup uh
so I I take it on on your
word representative would you would you
believe all right thank you very much
having no more cards we will close the
public
hearing
e